welcome back to you a healthcare giant
known for baby lotion and bandages will
be the defendant this morning when an
opioid related lawsuit goes to trial
the state of Oklahoma accuses Johnson
and Johnson of falsely downplaying the
risk of opioid addiction now this is a
first trial out of hundreds of lawsuits
against opioid manufacturers CTM
consumer investigative correspondent
Andrew Warner joins us at the table so
the question for you is what is the
expected trials outcome of this yeah
this expected trial I don't think
anybody knows that yet Gail but you know
almost two hundred eighteen thousand
Americans died from overdoses related to
prescription opioids
that's between 1997 and 2017 now
prosecutors across the US have blamed
deceptive marketing practices for
helping to fuel the crisis now we may
see if that argument holds up in court I
woke up one day and was addicted to
opiates and had no idea how that
happened Jamie Stafford says her
dependence on painkillers prescribed to
her after a 2007 car accident put a
financial and emotional strain on her
family my family couldn't understand
what was going on with me who was this
person that I had become while in
recovery she met Thomas now her husband
he had wound up addicted following a
2013 motorcycle crash I tried to have a
full conversation with my doctor about
lowering my dose and he ignored me at
the peak of the opioid epidemic
overdoses killed more than 500
Oklahomans a year in 2017 the state
filed a lawsuit accusing major
pharmaceutical companies of executing
massive and unprecedented marketing
campaigns misrepresenting the risks of
addiction making billions of dollars in
profits and leaving Oklahoma to bear the
enormous cost of the resulting public
health crisis and this isn't just a bad
thing it's a horrible thing Oklahoma
Attorney General Mike hunter sat down
with 22 copal last year
he's expected to deliver an opening
statement in today's trial they put
profits over patients whatever culture
existed in these companies that allow
debt to occur is something they need to
be held accountable for two of three
companies Purdue Pharma and
Havva pharmaceuticals will pay the state
millions after settling out of court
with no admission of wrongdoing that
leaves Johnson & Johnson and its
subsidiary Janssen pharmaceuticals
charged in the lawsuit with creating a
public nuisance it's a novel legal
approach says University of Kentucky law
professor Richard oznas public nuisances
traditionally involved activities on
land and injuries or damage to real
property this obviously doesn't fit that
paradigm at all more than 1,800 cities
counties and states have filed similar
lawsuits Ausmus says the outcome in
Oklahoma could dictate future strategy
the other states that have been lurking
in the background and haven't committed
themselves can reformulate their
theories and have another go at it
Janssen pharmaceuticals told CBS News in
a statement that the state's allegations
are baseless and unsubstantiated we
acted responsibly in providing
fda-approved pain medications the
company said and we are ready for trial
but Jamie Stafford says how dare them
not take responsibility upfront for what
they've caused well the trial in Norman
Oklahoma is expected to continue through
July there will be cameras in the
courtroom so the public may be able to
get a better glimpse of what happens at
trial and how will the two companies
settling out of court affect the trial
with Johnson & Johnson well you know the
law professor we spoke to points out
that as a maker of household products as
well as drugs Johnson & Johnson has PR
concerns that perhaps some of the other
companies might not share he actually
said that he expects to see a lot of
dirt flying and he wouldn't even be
surprised to see a settlement even
perhaps after the state presents its
case you got cameras in the courtroom
right so we've all these lawsuits 40
other states 1800 plus lawsuits around
the country this is our first chance to
see some of the evidence yeah and yeah
right the question is how much will we
see if it does settle you may not see it
all yea that's an incentive first
gentlemen my corner there in Oklahoma
he's got a lawyer on his team who lost
his son to an opioid overdose also
another one lost a nice so it's legal
it's also personal it's a lot of people
and cameras in the courtroom make a
difference to I think know how people
don't use
like that Anna thank you